crows only like they're very social
distancing type of birds like they know
who you are
um but they'll keep their distance
always they're not like magpies magpies
are
are really like cuddly and stuff but
there could be an
exception right what if this black crow
is just generally just super like nice
i don't i don't want to find out i also
don't want i want to respect its
wildness i don't want to make friends
with it i just want to
watch it heal and then fly away
but eventually what happens let's say
this let me just throw the scenario out
there
that a month goes by and he's just
just just hanging out
you know you know you know bertane they
just why is that they're hanging out
right right just hanging out right and
he's like you know what i mean
eating all the sashimi whatever we give
them right
baby you don't mean like that guy right
yeah
i will pick it by the neck and throw it
off the balcony no you won't i won't do
that but
that's extreme that was extreme that was
crazy that was crazy what i just said
no that was crazy that's a turn off my
vagina dried so much i may never have
sex with you again
i would i would love it i would love it
but uh just imagine the crow with like
little tiny bird floaties and like a
little tiny bird bath just made just for
it just living the hollywood life
and there's the comedy the birdbath
there's a comedy from george right there
the clown wants a bird back let that
sink in
i thought it was huge they're all
laughing at home they're all laughing at
home
just listen gilbert had to remove
himself off screen
what he said what do you say gilbert
bird bath
wait well first it was the decibel
volume
yeah yeah yeah a little bird floaties
yeah all right so let it sink just let
it sink in then
i like let's have a moment of silence
i have a moment of silence jesus for
that joke
i'm kidding look at the beginning of
ferris bueller's day off throwing it out
there baby i love you
it's all about risk you got it back it's
all about risk versus reward baby i
don't like when you do that
i know i love it because your step mom
comes over
in a little bikini oh okay up here
he's doubling down guys
why are we doing this thing i don't care
we're not going to we're not going to
continue until you
said george umbrella don't don't use
umbrella go ahead
my tie next door um what there's nothing
else that can hide in this
okay and bobby's out there with a little
uh cabana umbrella holding it over the
little leonard the crow come on
margarita mix i'm okay with a little fan
yeah and uh keeping them cool maybe
spritzing them off with like one of
those little fans with little spritzer
waters mm-hmm
okay very descriptive just a little bit
towel to let it sink in anyway
um i don't think it's [ __ ] i don't
know i love it
i love you george i love it so um what
do we do though so
a month goes dubai what do we do what do
you mean
if if if no service for starters i'm not
waiting a month i'm already in contact
with a wildlife rescue
if i have to somehow capture him get his
legs splinted
and rehabilitated that's what that's
what i'll do but my point in like
seeing if he'll get better on his own is
because i don't want to separate him
from his family his family is circling
above like oh yeah they do come they
don't